γανικόν ελεκτή ναι ννα θυμα που συζητείται των αυτές τις μέρες σήμερα που γυρίζεε το
επισόδιο είχε έσι κάποια θέματα με για νικό ελεκτήν πολλέ ει προστρίβες που είχε κάποιες
υποθέσεις μαζί του πορούσα να μεσενωτήσουμε μια φυλακοαδής εγώ το δύ χικιάτες δεν αβέντ ότα
περάσανέξι χρόνια θέρα πείας που έκανα εφελτι όθε καρπετά και ο παςότι μου νο τέλειος
ανθρωπος εκαλτιόθεγαεν ρκτά αλλα δημούργισαν α νέω στοδρόμα είχα το σύνρομο του ισούχριστύ τιπάσει τω
το πράγα υπάρχει ηαδη το ι όχε γις δεαπέντρει λέ υιάβασατόσον πολά εμτόσον πολλά και
έχαμα και πόναντικές αλλαγές ου ενομίσα ελθυμαι επίνα και στες εκπομπέες ε μιλούσαν με τον
πικελίδη στην ελίδα και τα λεπάγι τα λιμά με ένα οθέρα πευτίσμου που με κάνα
τα εθερα πίες έλεμου έχρι στο φορέσύλαλιμού ίσι έχνωστό τν κύπρο έχεις θύμι τούτα ολα
τα πράγματα που σουμεθέννο μπορεί μια ενήμερα να τα περάσει των λαόν της κύπρο και
τον αλλάξεις εα λεγμ εγ νιώθαντα τον το πράμα και κι θα λέωσωτων το πράγμα
το έν πράμο και λείω νμη μαθίστοτε εγνώρισα το γενικών ελεκτί λοιπόν και ξεκινήσαμε και
αλλά σισαμε μηνήματα εγώ ω ορκίζουμε μες το νούο είχα να το βοηθήσομ αφού ήταν
λέω του τι η θέση σημαντική για την κοινωνί να το βοηθήσω των των άνθρωπο
να αλλάξει α τούτα πωμαθα να τα παρκέψω τα μεταφέρω και αγραφας πούμε για την
τροπή για το φόβο ανμιούσαμε ναπαντούσε μου γιων πλάτω α λεών πιθαγόρα και τούτι κου
έντα πιες καιο χρόνια δύο χρόνια ρααλά σα μινήματα ελεμοεστελεμου μια ένα μήνυμα φίλεμου εγώ
τώρα έχω δουλιά να φέω πωσικόι καμαντα μαπορι και με εξέρω πάω από κιυπο απόδάμιλούσαμε
αμέσωσω τα πολύ λόγο καρφώς εμιλούσαμε τούτος εξεκίνησε μια διαδικασία και εκινία μέχωκαι τα αυτώ
χρόνα που μιλούς δηλαδή πίκάλεσε να σου πάναν παράδημασι στα γλήορα γιατί εαντάζουμ ρασου ευκάνεσε
την αστυνομία ένα πρωί στο αρχηγείο παρουσία ναστυνομικόν με όνομα και επίθετο